hey guys you've probably already noticed
that of all the Dragon Ball youtubers on
here I've never really reviewed each
individual episode of Super and by never
really I mean I never did like ever and
seeing as we are already years into
supers episodic run I don't expect you
to sit through 76 10 minute reviews of
episode you've already seen the reviews
for then I stumble upon this channel
called jello apocalypse and besides
possibly having the best channel name in
existence he caught my attention with
one video in particular that being every
Disney film reviewed in 10 words or less
where he reviewed 60 Disney films
rapid-fire within 10 words or less so
naturally I thought that's a great idea
for a video and it solved my problem of
how to catch up with all those other
pesky Dragon Ball youtubers as of making
this video there are currently 76 Dragon
Ball super episodes available for my
viewing pleasure all scores will be
whole numbers out of 10 which means
there'll be no numbers like 9.5 and
there might be a negative score - now
that doesn't mean that it's worse than a
zero out of ten no instead it measures
it's ironic enjoyment nothing in my
opinion is worse than boring so if
episode has spawned enjoyment from
ripping on how terrible it is then
terrific that means it qualifies for a
negative scrolling because you can make
fun of it and sometimes that's more fun
than just a boring episode these scores
will take into account all aspects of
the show including but not limited to
visuals and narrative now that that's
out of the way let's review every Dragon
Ball super episode in ten words or less
what is this real is this actually
happening yes
missed opportunity for Vegeta to wear a
certain pink shirt Frieza vs. Goku
flashback now with gorgeous modern
animation techniques
Goten trunks and peel off filler
nonsense repeat for 12 minutes pretty
much the reason I have any subscribers
at all emotional flashbacks make beerus
a more credible and rich character the
Jia's power from battle of gods now with
no budget rock paper doll for Koko
hey the dalles a Super Saiyan said way
too many people watching Goku learn to
harness his new abilities is fun a huge
improvement than animation suspense and
action there's definitely a fisting joke
here somewhere mr. Sainz the bravest
character in this arc the movie might
have looked better but this fight is
just better because of one joke I now
love this episode excellent character
acting make for exceptional episodes
oh yeah hilarious and totally
underappreciated I loved everything
about this episode
easily the most terrifying
interpretation of hell I've ever seen
huh I didn't know jock who worked in
episode 24 Frieza represents the ark
Takuma represents the viewers attention
span that moment you realize you can use
the most inspirational character the
most unenthusiastic boring murder I've
ever seen [ __ ] okay
this feels like a personal attack on my
integrity freeze is not the only one
getting tired of this wheeshes do-over
means there's an alternate timeline
where Frieza wins tournament 12
universes [ __ ]
Bulma is a sister yeah okay you can't
spell recap without Bobo's boobs or
super Dragon Balls which will you
remember what his beards and evil
winnie-the-pooh this episode wait
no okay but what oh I get it Frost's an
[ __ ] and he's gone Hey look a robot
it's always great to see the final flash
flow an episode full of great character
moments for Vegeta why has no one
mentioned his head's a giant penis
important episode that reminded us why
we watched the show I forgot that this
was basically a tournament for food poor
animation ruins what could have been a
huge moment really fun episode would
surprise beerus rematch goku lost his
key how will he ever get in it's mini
ark time I for one welcome our new
Julito overlord funny touching and much
better than golden freezers fight one of
the best Dragon Ball episodes ever made
1000 - good carry the just go back to
the fight bed I guess you could say
trunks missed the point
spontaneous interdimensional time for
Texas cutting great moment short since
truth if bullets did nothing to Raddatz
what's it like for black that moment the
crushing disappointment of Gohan hits
you zoom assume the story of the barista
that became space Hitler let me help you
son plows face into the ground god I
love this little [ __ ] how does Super
Saiyan rose' work who cares it's awesome
exciting suspenseful and really polished
episode also God - step 1 for good feng
shui foot table meadow holy crap when
beerus turns it on its on bulbous dinner
parties really put the Last Supper to
shame probably the best transformation
since Dragon Ball Z Mothra is cool but
didn't deliver in the last episodes
climax polished with epic moments but my
plan is so dump trucks
you have the power holy [ __ ] he actually
does apparently beams only work if
you're the main protagonist the amount
of pure action this episode has is
astounding unexpectedly somber end to a
reef on ark quirky little episode where
bull McGee's beers and we scraps Goku
would totally kick saitama's ass right
guys that empty void in my life has
suddenly been filled
wait what Goku state oh he's not neat I
can show you the world shining
shimmering splendid quickly great salmon
stop any Brock I mean very Khan daddy
why are you a [ __ ] Shinji Kino Dragon
Ball and that's all of them as of
recording this video no naturally I
don't expect you to want to go back
through this list to see which ones are
the best and the worst so here are my
top and bottom five Dragon Ball super
episodes top 5 number 5 episode 57 this
is the kind of episode that will bring a
smile to your face featuring the best
animation of this arc it brings tons of
action with our main characters either
down or cornered and never leaves you
waiting for something to happen unless
what you're waiting for is nothing
number 4 episode 18 presenting possibly
the funniest episode in the series this
one follows Goku and Vegeta as they
train together with Wiese in an
assortment of different and fun
scenarios it's a shame this is buried in
an act that almost everyone will skip
because it's easily one of the best
number three episode 39 this is the
episode that turns the awesome from 10
to 25
featuring the climax to the tournament
no Monica doesn't count
bringing fanfictions across the world to
life goku uses the kaio-ken in tandem
with his super saiyan blue for
delivering a moment no Dragon Ball fan
will ever forget number 2 episode 66
described by many as the best-looking
episode in Dragonball history this
behemoth of an episode crams two battles
into its run time it acts as the climax
to the arc featuring the return of
vegeto briefly and a spirit sword
wielded by trunks does it make sense of
course not
but look pretty pictures and the number
one best episode so far goes to episode
47 haunting new scores accompany a
darker plotline delivers an
hence episode following up for the first
time in this series with Future Trunks
as he flees an imposing shadowy figure
this was exactly the kind of episode
Dragon Ball super needed when it came
out the visuals stunning the narrative
captivating and the stakes were
extremely hot if you're unsure of Oh
checking out super or know someone who's
on the fence I can't recommend a single
episode more it's that good but who
cares about the best of anything right
if my worst video I mean my worst
moments video is anything to go by
people only really want to know how
horrible something is because nothing's
more fun than basking the abuse of
someone else's content so here we go the
bottom 5 number 5 episode 4 this guy
avoids criticism by existing next to the
meme factory that is episode 5 and what
it largely looks better that's where the
pros end at least
episode 5 continued the narrative this
serves only to Pat out a story that
desperately needed more character
development more than the POF gang
looking for food anyway number 4 episode
12 hey you guys want to know what filler
in a fight looks like this amidst the
Battle of the Gods comes this wonderful
little gem of an episode featuring key
dragons and fist clashes between Goku
and beerus that threatened to shatter
the entire universe I know what you're
thinking well that's dumb and doesn't
make sense at all number 3 episode 25
filled with absolutely nothing original
except bad art animation and a fight
that feels longer than the first even
though it's a fraction of its length
this episode offers nothing except a new
form of cruel and unusual torture number
2 episode 30 this is one of those recap
episodes but the biggest difference is
that it covers events that literally
just happened this is an episode that
exists purely to give the animators
breathing room to make the next episode
a couple of scenes here and there with
goku vegeta keep this from being a one
out of 10 and the absolute worst episode
is episode 24 this is the absolute worst
of the worst when i think of a bad or
downright terrible Dragon Ball
installment this abortion of an episode
springs to mind
episode 5 spawned some hilarious spoofs
that had undeniably albeit brief great
moments this episode arguably looks
worse and the only thing you've realized
is that you've wasted 22 minutes of your
life watching two scribbles clumsily
stumble their way through it nari
forcing you to question why are you even
watching this in the first place
[Music]
you